hi there
i'm just going to have to adjust my ipad
so that it doesn't go off every five
minutes
just do that here
i'll be right with you i'm gonna talk
about learning words today
and uh but here we go display brightness
on my ipad and it says uh
blah blah blah where is it now
uh auto lock we want to go never so it
doesn't shut off while we're doing this
because i rely on my ipad to see the
questions that people uh submit
because i can't see that on my feed here
so and that's why in any demonstrations
i do i
use the computer but of course
most of what i do on the computer i can
do on our
app in my in
either ios or android
so
uh hello everyone
uh first of all thank you to all my
viewers on youtube i now have 150 000
subscribers
so that's nice i guess i don't know
between 149 150 000.
big deal maybe
um now i often get asked
how do you memorize vocabulary
how do you learn words
how do you learn when at the beginning
you know know
words and so this got me to thinking
so i'm gonna
ramble a little bit and then i'm gonna
demonstrate on the screen
so
the first thing is
um
if i think of my arabic
or persian
i actually know quite a lot of words
um
2 500 words in persian
closing in on 8 000 words in arabic
now you can challenge these statistics
it's not very scientific it's just the
way
it's just the way link counts them um
but
the fact is as i will demonstrate if i
bring an article in from al jazeera
in
arabic or something similar in farsi i
actually know a lot of the words there
so i have learned these words but i
haven't memorized them i have put zero
effort into memorizing them i don't
memorize
i have done some random flash guarding
which i will also demonstrate as i turn
the page in my lessons
but i haven't tried to memorize and to
me flash card is just
sort of concentrated exposure to some
words and phrases
i don't try to memorize them i don't
test myself on them i just expose myself
to them and gradually the words stick
so that's the first thing to say
the second thing is
uh while making breakfast i was
listening to story number 56 in persian
because i i'm in my persian part of the
week right now i was in my arabic for
the first part of the week
and actually understanding more and more
of these uh
you know podcasts that are live
authentic from france valkette arabic
out of france or al jazeera i'm
understanding more and more of them and
i'll show you how that is happening
but so i realized that i understand more
and more
and with the many stories of course i
find the mini story is very powerful if
i start a new language that's what i
would use
i'm on story 56 now in persian and there
are some words there that i simply don't
know what they mean
i know the story because i've done the
story in other languages so i can kind
of guess at what the word might be
depending on where in that sentence it
shows up
but as i listen to the story and the
story course repeats the same vocabulary
with a different person or different
tense and then the vocabulary is
repeated in in questions
and so i hear it again and of course the
way we learn vocabulary is to my mind is
when the other pieces of the puzzle of
the jigsaw puzzle are there because i
know
like say in this i'll show you the farsi
or persian story that i'm listening to i
know most of the words but there's a
couple of dozen words there that i don't
know
and so i hear them i hear them again and
again
and as i listen to them and i miss them
i have a rough idea what they might be
then i become very curious to go and
read that lesson and in order to go over
those words again
and then listen again
and so that is how the many stories
through sort of this process of
repetition and and listening to create
curiosity and then reading and saving
words and reviewing the words and
listening again
gradually the result is that in my of my
arabic and persian mini stories
all of the words in the first
40 lessons i know them that's all part
of my vocabulary many of them i can use
because i've heard them so often i use
them in conversation with my tutor
mostly
so so the process is not one of
memorization the process is one of
exposing yourself to
uh
a variety of material bearing in mind
that
you know
70
whatever 50 60 70 80 of the content will
be high frequency stuff that shows up
all the time
and this then becomes the framework
around which you then pursue these more
specific words all right so that's my
way of introduction and now i'm going to
share my screen
and
talk a bit about what i do and then i
look forward to your questions
so
all right here we are
and i'm going to share
hopefully this is the screen that i want
to share
and desktop too
start screening
okay present to everyone
so
now it's just that i was going to
demonstrate i went to this uh
part uh persian website to import a uh
but before doing that here's what i want
to do
let
let us open another tab
in a
link here
okay it takes me to my arabic but i'm
not going to do arabic i'm going to go
to indonesian
indonesian is a language that i have not
done at link
and
we at the present time we have 35
mini stories uploaded and i think we'll
eventually get to the 60. we have to
have 60 mini stories or we would not
have
uh launched this as a language so they
must just not have been uploaded yet so
if i open this
uh then i see the stories and of course
it's a hundred percent
unknown words i don't know a single word
in indonesia
so i opened the first story now
one thing one advantage i have of course
is that i know the story because i've
done this in greek
in persian
in arabic
i think i played with it in slovak
so i know the story but nevertheless
but i do know from experience
that first of all
indonesia has the tremendous advantage
of being written
in the latin alphabet advantage for me
because the latin alphabet of course is
the alphabet that i am most familiar
with
for a native speaker of chinese or or
russian that may not be the case for a
native speaker of russian obviously a
language that's written in the cyrillic
alphabet is going to be much easier
but uh so all of this is unknown you'll
notice the numbers are not highlighted
because we don't count numbers as part
of your sort of
growing known word total
but i know
that if i were to spend a month going
through these stories
all of these words here will become part
of my vocabulary because everything i
look at in
i'll show you in in arabic or farsi not
everything but most the words there i
can sit and know
so
uh how do you get from
this to where they're known well i begin
by looking at work
so
you know following okay i have no idea
how that is
with the uh ini
ini
adela
i get used to after a while is that
where this could be a name so when there
are names
the um the system or the dictionaries
that we use and probably this is still
in uh
google translate
tries to translate the name i presume
the person's name is
verified phrases that i could uh
are these phrases that other people have
saved i might want to say
now that may even be a wrongly
translated phrase let's see what we have
in the way of dictionaries
we have little translate and blah blah
that's all we have hmm
verb conjugator
let's take this
story
all right i think story looks like a
very large
dictionaries blah blah let's see
let's see what pablo says
in english account recital tale yarn
story that looks pretty good so i've
added the blabla dictionary now in many
languages we would have more
dictionaries to choose from uh it's
that's okay but very good ini adela
so immediately
this is
so as you see i'm working my way through
this thing it's just my the beginning of
of trying to discover this language
uh i can listen to it
[Music]
so
just to show you what it looks like when
i start a new language from zero and i
would be confident that
in because the latin this is a latin
alphabet i would say that a few months
and i will plow my way through
at least 40 of these stories if not more
okay so then
let us look at what do we got here which
language are in arabic so if i go
in arabic
to
um
let's say that i have of course my
conversation reports al jazeera podcasts
i got alex
emil here
and we got the many stories in standard
arabic we also have them by the way in
levantine arabic but let's open these
so i still have um
in story one
i can see that i have
one word here that i don't con
completely feel that i know
um
these are the sort of early stories zero
zero you know four one
thirty eleven for whatever reason there
are some blue words there i could open
that one up and see what's going on
uh that's strange
that could be something wrong in our
strange
it shows that no words that i don't know
so i know all of this i know all of
these words
i don't know why that show must best be
a refresh issue or something i don't
know however
now if i go
to
let's say that i go to al jazeera here
al jazeera
click on al jazeera
no that's not the al jazeera i wanted i
wanted that's the
learning let's teach you arabic al
jazeera i wasn't
tremendously keen on that so i go to al
jazeera
and i pick something
all right
so here's this text
then i click on the uh
extension
and of course i'm not in persian i'm in
arabic
and this is al jazeera so
where am i going to put it al jazeera
as opposed to podcast where i have sound
so i import this
so now this is you know coming straight
out of
something that is intended for
uh an arabic speaking audience
so i have 75 new words
but look at this you know
not so many new words
lots of words that i'm in the process of
learning in fact 90 of them and all but
a lot of white words words that i
already know and that has been through a
a process
of of gradually learning the language in
the way that i described so the same
would happen
if i go to
where are we here
if i go to this is the uh
radio for europe
uh this is uh
farsi
or persian
and if i now go
to
the import extension
and this is now
persian
and we're going to call this they call
this thing fardo
and i'm gonna import it
it takes a little while hopefully it'll
work sometimes it doesn't work
oh there we are
so
now persian now of course persian i've
really only been working on
in any sort of concentrated way since
january
so
lots more blue words
but still yellow words
and white words
right
now
one thing that i could perhaps show you
okay i'm in let's go to uh
let's do it this way we open this up we
go to
uh view course
oh i should have shown you this so while
i'm in this
it's worth knowing
that first of all i can add it to a
playlist i have already added the
playlist but i've since removed it
because i can only have 100 lessons in
my playlist
but i wanted to show you that for all of
these
translations are available because
they're mini stories so if i go
to where i was here 56 i got 17
and 57 you know here as i'm reaching the
end of these many stories there's lots
of words
there's no new words because i've been
through them a few times
but
there are words that i haven't yet
learned
so
if i go
to
story 56
actually i was doing it in persian
before but look at it
people comment on how poor the text to
speech is it doesn't really matter
because i listen to the actual natural
voice
so she's very good
uh the text of speech but it does help
and it certainly is a disadvantage that
in persian we don't have text-to-speech
but typically in this lesson what i
would do
is when i turn the page down here
i would go through
the flashcards so that's when i
flashcard when i'm sort of engaged with
a piece of content i want to try to nail
things down
uh
and then i would do the dictation
flashcards etc so i've kind of used up
i'm wondering if there's anything else
that i should
no so that's good enough so uh
stop
and here i am back okay so there you
have it like so it's this natural
process
of um of going through the lessons
and listening doing a lot of listening
uh
that enables me to acquire these words
and um many of them some are required
through sort of deliberate flash carding
but uh many of them are required
simply through
um
listening reading
exposing myself to the words all right
now let us see what we have here
and the way of questions all right
okay
do you have any experience with
translating or interpreting what about
it did you like or not like well
when i was working in um tokyo and even
in hong kong after i finished my chinese
first of all we had to translate for our
tests we had to translate
from english to chinese from chinese to
english so that was part of my
preparation
we had to translate newspaper editorials
from english into chinese and so forth
when i was in the embassy in japan and
subsequently as a businessman there
i regularly had visitors from canada and
so i was regularly in situations of
interpreting as i was in china and
in hong kong so but this was sort of
informal
uh
you know
[Music]
not uh whatever they call it it's it's
sort of sequential uh interpreting and
not uh
whatever it is i forgot
i don't interpret while the person is
talking
i listen to the person then i try to say
sequentially um
what did i think of it well one of the
bigger problems is that a lot of people
don't speak their own language very well
so sometimes you have to interpret what
they're saying
um but yeah i mean it's just something
you do i'm comfortable in both languages
so i hear what the person has to say and
then i simply say it in the
language of the other participants
uh stephen again through kupara prender
you know there is no true ku para
aprender 30 idiomas
uh
it's the same as uh
to learn one language
a lot of listening
what is your username on the link forms
that's not addressed to me would you
continue to do this questionnaire every
few weeks or so after the night they're
highly enjoyable well i i could you know
i mean i do have my regular uh
videos that i've been putting out i
could turn one of the two into this kind
of q a session i think that's a good
idea uh we'll talk about it
uh if i said hello my teacher how are
you advising from morocco i'm beginning
to learn english three months ago i
learned a lot on youtube i have
typically speaking you're doing very
well feisty you're doing very well by
the way i enjoyed visiting your country
uh my wife and i were in fest and took a
bus up to chefchaouen lovely countryside
friendly people we lived in the medina
which was an experience
uh but it was great i enjoyed it
uh it's not right are you ever worried
that the content you read is too varied
making it less likely that you encounter
the same words over and over again
um
okay the many stories focus on the most
frequently used verbs in the language
very important in order to speak
uh
thereafter i once i move out of the
comfort zone of the sort of
you
know content for learning the language
and i move into content of interest
then um you know i was listening and and
studying in uh
from the uh from
podcast so i have done something on
brexit which is a lot of economic terms
immigrants and refugee arabic immigrants
and refugees in europe so that talks
about refugees and immigrants uh you
know the political situation in algeria
uh someone who's an arab a palestinian
who's
planning to run for mayor in
jerusalem so there's a variety of
different topics there but it's it's
kind of focused on my interest economics
politics history so yeah there's a
certain amount of repetition if i were
going to
i wouldn't venture into literature i
wouldn't venture into a religion i
wouldn't venture into you know nuclear
physics so
as long as i stay in sort of history
current events
um i think i'm okay
uh i find that correctly a few days ago
you talked about releasing george and i
link is that correct yes we have someone
who has volunteered to find a group of
people to
create the mini stories in georgian and
if we receive these we have heard some
audio samples they're good
and so now they have to go ahead and do
it and if they do it we will upload
georgian
coco says my listening ability has
lagged far beyond my reading ability you
have any tips for that i've been
struggling listening to the readings
i've read months ago which is boring to
me but it's all i could do well
you know um
what i'm doing obviously reading is is
you understand more when you read in
particular if as in my case i read on my
ipad or on the computer i can look up
the words i can pick my way through it
but then having invested
that time in sort of deciphering what is
to be difficult probably for you reading
is not difficult but for me in arabic or
persian it's difficult
then i listen to the same content
uh
how do i get the transcript there are
automatic transcription services
available that aren't very expensive
uh i what i would do if i were you is i
would find stuff
to listen to that you like
okay and so you listen you don't
understand now what are you gonna do get
it transcribed so look up for example
vocalmatic or look up automatic
transcription and then for ten dollars a
month or so you can get a lot of stuff
transcribed
and so you listen you don't understand
now you're curious what did i miss then
you go and read it you see what you
missed sometimes you just couldn't hear
it properly sometimes you don't know the
word
and again the more of that thing you're
listening to the more of it you
understand the easier it will be to
understand the rest so it's a gradual
it's this whole jigsaw puzzle thing the
more of the pieces you put together the
more you're going to understand so you
do have to do a lot of listening but if
you listen and don't understand
don't just leave it try and get it
transcribed and anything that's new and
fresh like if you subscribe i could show
you how i subscribe to all these
podcasts in different languages if you
subscribe to a podcast service and
you're getting fresh material which you
have transcribed that's always better
than doing something old i have old
transcribed podcasts
uh in arabic i'm not interested in them
anymore i'm more interested in the
latest podcast so i would rather spend a
little money and get the latest podcast
transcribed rather than going over again
something that i've done before try and
keep it interesting the brain likes
novelty
um okay
it's just a matter of time what do you
plan to do with your okay
have i noticed any similarity being
farsi and french yes i have
you know the use of the co okay
uh
there's some things in there i mean
obviously there are some long words but
even in terms of structure
uh there are similarities you know the
use of the role
as a
divider or sort of a marker of the uh
i guess the subject of the sentence is
similar to japanese
uh there are different similarities
there the more languages you know the
more you notice similarities between the
new language and one that you already
know
salaam
[Applause]
because you're studying the words out of
any context and the one definition of
using might be a mistake i absolutely
agree uh you can look up a definition
but it's not a definition of the word
it's just a suggestion as to
kind of what the meaning might be and
you have to see the word in different
contexts before you get a clearer
picture of the range of meanings that it
can have and that's again
why i don't mind as part of my learning
listening to my mini stories over and
over again
because not only am i trying to get a
handle on the words that i don't know
and and i become more and more curious
now to read it to see what that word was
and i look it up and i know what it is
and the next time i hear it i don't
understa don't know what it is anymore
but it's all the other words
that you are getting at clear the frame
the other words you're also getting a
clearer and clearer picture of those
words so
yeah
uh um
you know the dictionary definition
doesn't do it it's a step it's a step
yeah
vergara i agree with him he's a great
guy and listen an hour a day absolutely
build up vocabulary every single day and
don't try to memorize
yeah
from china yes and this emphasis on
memorization it makes it uninteresting
it destroys the motivation to learn the
language it's ineffective it's it's a
waste of time
um i don't know why people do that
i don't see why you couldn't combine
memorizing flashcards and learning words
in context
sure i mean if that's what you want to
do i
however you memorize words i think it is
a less effective way of learning
vocabulary than
simply exposing yourself to more and
more of the language and i do use
flashcards but not with the goal of
memorizing them i don't test myself i
don't
you know look at the target language
word and try and remember what it means
i don't i just flash go through it it's
kind of like a concentrated exposure
to the words that i have still trouble
with one thing i sometimes do in
reviewing all the lessons rather than
reading through the whole lesson i'll
just go through
the flashcards the words that i still
have trouble with it's just exposure
it's not an attempt to memorize
i try to learn five different words in a
day but it's not easy to remember all
the words no don't expect to remember
this is from uv casing don't expect to
remember just expose yourself to the
words
and after you reach a very large
agreement do you mainly just import i
found it for in spanish there's pretty
much nothing in the yeah i would say
even before 40 000 words very early on i
am
i mean i look to see what's in the link
library i follow the feed i see what
other people are studying sometimes
there's things there that interest me
but it's so much easier to go on the
internet to find
podcasts articles of interest ebooks
that you can import ebooks for which
there are audio books so the internet
becomes the library
ultimately
and that's why not only the internet but
in particular things like youtube songs
movies where there's closed captions you
can import those
in the end link is simply a platform now
we provide not everyone wants to look
for content so we also provide content
in link but the really sort of motivated
independent learner is going to want to
go out and search for things
yeah i mean edward likes a answer male
that's fine uh assimila
does explain the grammar we have by the
way
uh
a grammar resource and if you go
to your
uh
profile your picture
those notifications settings profile
academy oh
that's not where it is
somewhere
hmm i can't remember where oh maybe
because in in arabic we don't have a
grammar if i go to uh i'm just looking
at my screen here if i go to polish for
example
and i go to my profile it's got a
grammar guide so in a lot of languages
the main languages we have a grammar
guide which you can have a look at
uh do you need to buy premium or use
these functions uh you need to be a
paying member like
uh
saving words and phrases you're maxed
out at i think 20 if you don't pay and i
think importing your maxed out at five
if you don't pay
so it's it's well worth it
how do you put asset mail on your link
do you have an easy way i have my teach
yourself lessons on link but it's a lot
of work okay what i did with assimilate
i
because i bought assimil
i actually approached small and i said
could you give me a digital version so i
can learn on link as well i also said
would you allow us to sell assimil
across link integrated with our system
which i think our learners would
appreciate and they hemmed and had and
stuff and they so far haven't agreed
someone from assimil will be at the
polyglot conference in fukuoka i'm going
to try again
but what i did was i simply had i
transcribed
the uh audio files for arabic i paid
someone to do it so that's very accurate
uh with the persian i went to the sort
of automatic transcription
and there you get the odd word that
is not
correct but it's pretty good like it's
well over 90
and you don't get any punctuation which
is a bit of a problem at times but the
point is that
i can't share these but for my own use i
was able by getting the having bought
smail
owning the audio files either paying
someone to transcribe which is expensive
or using the automatic transcription
service which is not quite perfect
getting them in to link as lessons
and then i of course add in the audio
files so that i have the audio file for
each lesson
yeah i agree with slappy white i mean
you can do anything you can try to
memorize you can do whatever you want
but you have to decide where you want to
spend your time
uh
how did you get a job at link okay
gonna be honest with you mate you don't
know the grammar rules in your native
language so why should you learn
whatever language you're learning
yeah i mean again it comes back to this
idea of exposure i see nothing wrong in
reviewing the grammar i think it's it's
kind of self-defeating to try to
memorize the grammar rules because it's
not in the end going to help you uh
that much but to review them from time
to time it helps you notice certain
things in the language it helps to
explain things that you have come across
uh blah blah blah blah all things
consider you say english is more similar
to german germanic germanic languages or
romance languages well i think grammar
wise is
i think more similar to germanic
languages but vocabulary
is
more similar to
the most common words of english are
more similar to germanic languages
the more
academic or whatever words are much more
similar to romance languages
okay
when studying two languages do you study
one language in the morning and one in
the afternoon okay so this is my first
experience studying two languages
sort of equally i have in the past have
gone eighty percent one twenty percent
the other so what i chose to do
was to spend the first half of the week
in persian and the second half of the
weekend
and i've stayed with them
now is that the best way to do it i
don't know uh you kind of get into it
really get into it then you have to go
to the other language but i feel if i
were to do two the same day
i would never really get into it and if
i were to leave one for two weeks and
then go back to the other one or
seriously study run for two weeks and go
to the other one i'm afraid i would slip
too much so i've chosen to go three days
on three days off
uh in the month of may i want to go
after improving my russian and ukrainian
so i haven't yet decided how i'm gonna
do that i'm even thinking of sneaking in
some pose we'll see what happens
okay some more uh indonesia which i
don't know
okay personally from b2 into c1 and c2
uh yeah i think
that the that the early stages getting
just like a2
it's kind of
not easy it's a lot of hard work but it
happens fairly quickly and you have the
sense that you now have some
understanding of the language but
thereafter it's a long road from b1 to
b2 is a long road from b2 to c1 is a
long road and so forth and i think the
main thing to do is to find things you
enjoy
in the language enjoy the language
and just don't worry about your language
because it will improve if you continue
reading and listening and speaking and
occasionally reviewing the grammar
uh
uh do any of the languages you know have
and it have entire tenses only used in
writing well french for example
uh has that
um i mean
chinese has a very sort of dense concise
form of the language which is used in
newspapers and it's kind of more
different
all language is very you know are a
little bit different you know we're
obviously more casual that's why
for example
in any language i find that you know
excellent learning material for
intermediates is conversations natural
conversations that are that are then
subsequently transcribed because
we use less vocabulary when speaking
whereas when writing we look for more
you know precise words and somewhat you
know lower frequency words but so in all
languages there's a difference between
the spoken and written language
but
in some languages it's greater so
there's a tense in french and italian
that
you know that um
is only used when writing
article 11 impact link uh we're not
worrying about it
um
[Music]
right now uh we will see uh i think we
rely on people to be responsible and not
share stuff that they don't have the
rights to we can't possibly police it
if it turns out that this that we can't
we can no longer
allow people to uh
to you know or you know maybe we have to
set up a system where we review
everything before it's uploaded
we'll wait to see
and what is your philosophy of life you
want that in three words or less
you know
my philosophy of life is
that um
you know
enjoying life is very subjective and
personal
and so you have to find things that
value that have value for you
family friends food
travel
enjoying the colors that you see
the scenery
uh
and enjoying
you know having valuable relations with
people and helping people and uh
you know some sense of sort of
reciprocity if you treat people well
somewhere down the line other people
will treat you well and if everybody is
helpful to everyone then
it's a nicer place to be
and don't take advantage of people
um now hello steve it's about to add
languages spoken by two million people
in link if we can provide enough content
i mean bashkirian okay
interesting question
um
you know we added we added bulgarian
which is more than two million people we
added gujarati which is i don't know 30
40 million people these are not
languages in high demand
uh
i think we could add a basket
i don't know
you know it comes a point like
uh so bashkirian i presume is written in
the cyrillic alphabet i don't know
nothing about bachelion i don't know how
similar bastirian is to tata
we have turkish we can add other turkic
languages turkish of course is written
in the latin alphabet
um
i mean i'm not against it if we get the
60-minute stories done then we have to
you know honor our commitment we will
put it up um
absolutely so yeah if you can get that
done we will put it up uh the answer is
yes we would
um
okay
some indonesian going on there
why does it cost too much to talk and
link
the thing is the tutors can set their
own rates
so if someone says uh the tutor is
willing to talk for ten dollars an hour
uh link takes fifteen percent so that's
standard italki is the same and the
tutors set their own rates
currently trying to decide because
learning finnish or hungarian are both
compelling in terms of culture and
linguistics but having a tough time
deciding between two there's not much i
can say how often should i be reviewing
words and link i don't think there's a
rule i just tend to review them
you know when i'm going through a lesson
if if i have
like 30 40 on you know yellow links in
that lesson that's too much for me to go
through in review but page to page i
might do it
i do it when that
when i feel like it there is no
there i don't think there is a rule it's
the thing about it reviewing words
reading listening talking
these are all a variety of activities
that we can uh get
you know engage in so variety is good so
sometimes i don't feel like reading
sometimes i want to just flip through my
flashcards uh the key thing is to stay
active with your language
so there is no there is no rule there
we got some indonesian going here any
recommendations for exposure where you
are studying a non-written language i'm
studying tunisia and arabic and struggle
with how to review words
and not much i can say i mean there is
emil i think has a book on tunisia and
arabic
uh so you'd have to look for resources
like that um
yeah i really don't know uh
because the strange thing in the arab
world is that everything that is written
is written in standard arabic and yet in
each country they speak a slightly
different or
very different version
of the language so i i can't help you
there
ah i think you're giving advice for
those who aren't for fun if not for fun
uh memorizing vocabulary i wonder if you
didn't memorize vocab when you were
being paid to learn chinese
um
not really not really like i i think
with chinese and and to learn the
characters you are talking about a form
of memorization and i've explained
before that for the first thousand
characters
what i did was write them out
you know i have flash cards i write them
out put the flash card down write the
next one out put the flash card down and
then pretty soon have to write the first
one again and i went through this every
day i would put in 30 minutes to an hour
into learning characters that's very
specific
um any any alphabet typewriting system
where you there's 30 or 50 or 25 letters
you don't have to do that just by
reading the language you gradually get
better and better at reading the
language after my first thousand
characters
every time i came across a new character
i would just write it out a few times
and after i saw it often enough
i was able to learn so
uh you know this sort of distinction of
whether
you're doing it for work or for pleasure
i think
the learning process is not so different
ah
[Music]
okay should someone have b2 after one
year
uh um
i don't know what that
means uh in which language uh so forth
you know wait a second where are we
i lost my place somehow popped out here
somewhere
wait a second let me pop back here ah
should someone have bq after one year uh
i think if it's a language similar to
one you know and you put in a lot of
time you can do it i had full-time
exposure to chinese i think i achieved
d2 after one year
first time
still learning language electricity all
right andrew thank you how can i become
better at using more complex words and
not just be able to understand them well
ultimately if you hear them more often
read them more often
see them in phrases you'll eventually
start using them and don't hesitate
don't be reluctant to use them even if
you're not entirely sure that that it's
the appropriate place to use it
eventually sometimes you know you kind
of hesitate it's the right place to use
the word just go for it and eventually
you'll get a better sense of how to use
them
how can without memorize and analyze i'm
listening to our per day i don't like
grammar and i'm just reading and review
exactly please give me the right way
please i'm learning english okay i mean
hamza
yeah you got to trust the system just
keep reading and listening
uh i would review the grammar from time
to time and the more you listen and read
the more familiar you are with the
language the more useful the grammar
explanations will be
uh
yeah reading more complex material that
will give you more complex words
in my experience it just comes with time
yes
okay
people complaining about grammar even
though it's not easy
i don't understand
what do we do we're in a hurry to learn
a language spend more time at it
uh are you concerned with the different
active and passive listening um
i'm not entirely sure what that is
uh when i listen most of my listening is
done while doing other tasks
and i fade in and out
and that's kind of why i listen i never
sit down it's okay i'm gonna focus i'm
gonna listen i don't do that so i don't
know what what the definition of active
and passive
listening is if passive listening is
just to have some noise on in the
background that you don't understand
that i don't think is very useful and i
don't do that
okay
well phrasal verbs is just another form
of it's another phrase it's another part
of the language with enough exposure you
will get better
uh at
understanding them
um
you know a phrasal verb verb if it were
one
you know composite word
then it's just another item of
vocabulary i don't see that as a problem
uh the lack of people to speak to is a
problem
and um
so
uh
you know try to find people online to
talk to you eventually and i see from
your written english here that your
english is very good
eventually you have to find someone to
talk to because to speak well you have
to speak a lot now if that opportunity
isn't there i wouldn't worry about it i
would continue to build up my potential
comprehension vocabulary so that when
the opportunity does arise you can take
full advantage the georgian translations
are done we are waiting on the final
recordings of all 60 mini stories so the
person that was asking about georgian
rich who's coordinating the project with
our man zoran in serbia
he says that we're waiting for the
recording so that's good news thank you
rich
appraisal verbs nightmare i don't see
the of course i'm not a learner of
english but the phrasal verbs i think i
would just treat them and they exist in
other languages even though
sort of certain common verbs show up get
take whatever
uh ignore that and treat the whole thing
as a as a separate vocabulary item that
has to be learned on its own and uh the
fact that it includes uh give take put
whatever common verb
is is kind of a hint to hang your hat on
but don't assume you know the meaning
just because you know one of the words
in the phrasal verb
so you look it up every time if i'm on
link i say that if i'm learning english
i say that phrasal verb i don't make any
assumptions about the meaning of that
phrasal verb
so yeah phrasal verbs exist in german as
well how often do you review your links
when the answer when i feel like it and
do i no i don't complete the
cards that are due i i don't do that at
all i only review
in conjunction with a lesson that i'm
studying
and i do it on a random basis i enjoy
doing it
yeah here another person confirming you
have to treat them as verb as words yeah
they're just words
ah the phrasal verbs
are you left no
is it it's difficult because in
portuguese language they simply don't
exist
um
i would have to
check through portuguese to make sure
that uh
that there's no phrasal verbs
i bet you there are i bet you there are
but i don't have time
ah do you
opinions of aj att i get asked that a
lot i simply don't know and i wouldn't
want to give an opinion without knowing
the subject in depth do you have any
tips keywords for finding intermediate
level transcribed conversations all of
the ones i have found here at a1a2 level
i don't have any tips on that
uh we did you know we have in the past
asked our members
to
talk to their friends
spouses whatever children
natural conversations and then
transcribe them we have at link we have
our link podcast which we paid people to
do which are natural conversations
uh
obviously the you know the podcast that
al jazeera frontline those are natural
conversations they're a little difficult
uh i used to i used a lot of uh echo
musculee
i must be because there's so many
interviews every day when i was doing
uh ukrainian or masqueradio and now by
the way because i found this automatic
transcription service
i will uh get those transcribed
um
the ideal thing would be if more link
members would produce more natural
conversations in their native language
with people around them and transcribe
now because uh it's easy to speak it's
more work to transcribe anyway if we can
get those transcribed that would be
great
did an hour of listening while walking
that's the best way to do it can you
tell me about oh someone asked me
somewhere about my level was
in
chinese
anyways uh
i think it was time i don't know i've
lost that
uh
duh duh
okay
i think that was the question but if
someone if that was the question i think
i'm probably a me too in mandarin
chinese do you have any tips for funny
english right approximately
no no korean what level are you in
korean
okay system tells me i know 40 000 words
in korean
uh i can fight my way through political
podcasts podcasts and literature i
struggle to speak
uh i think i'm a be i'm a sort of
between b1 i'm i'm past b1
and working my way towards b
and uh i am committing myself
to uh
when i come back from ukraine i'm going
to focus on korean i want to get myself
to a solid b2
uh in the summer even though it means
for the time being putting my
persian and arabic on hold
are you going to make more advanced mini
stories as a sequel to the 61st i would
like to do that
uh i'd like to get maybe more people
asking for it uh
maybe
you know if john kr i don't know what
your native language language is uh if
you would write many stories and i
address this to anyone
go see the pattern in the mini stories
like
we have a story in say a given tense or
a given person
and then the same story in a different
tense or different person and then we
have a series of questions
about the story and typically in the
question we provide the answer in the
question like
uh
john went to the store did john go to
the store so that you don't have to
think about what was in this the story
and so that's the pattern so if people
will write stories in their native
language english or anything else
on more complex subjects business
travel literature whatever it might be
then that gives us a story for which we
can then translate
and have recorded in other languages so
john kr if you can provide us with some
stories we can work towards adding them
in different languages
and also tell me
which languages you're most interested
in
you can send me anyone can send me an
email steveatlink.com
simplified chinese versus traditional
chinese okay
when i learned chinese we started with
the traditional
and then we converted to
uh
simplified in order to read the material
from mainland china don't forget i was
studying in hong kong
and there's not a huge difference
from memory it seems a lot of the
simplification simply takes the sort of
cursive script like the handwritten form
of the character and makes that then the
printed form of the character
uh
i like the traditional characters i must
admit right now when i read them i i'm
almost not aware of which one i'm
reading
it's not it's not such a big difference
um that's my thought on that
is the reading and listening and
speaking without using papers and
memorizing another enough i'm not
listening to as a day one art for
reading and speaking many stories effort
yeah i mean
who knows what's enough you have to put
in time with the language
and uh
occasionally review the grammar
okay
which are similar to arabic sounds okay
can you remember how to write
japanese kanji i can't write them by
hand no but i can
write them on my computer
how to get unstuck in vocabulary volume
in german i mean i think that's where
link really shines
you just have to do a lot of of reading
of more and more difficult content in a
format like link where you can look
words up and and then the system keeps
them because otherwise you look the word
up you forget the meaning you forget
that you ever saw the word before and
you have to kind of keep going back to
these words in different contexts and
when you see them as yellow words then
you see them in another context of
another context and that's the gradual
process
uh i i think the vocabulary volume in
german is no greater than in russian or
in spanish or english or chinese it's
the same
what's your favorite reading matter in
your target language history
history i find that this from skyrim
history
definitely because i'm interested in the
language the history the culture and
stuff and uh non-fiction is easier than
fiction so i tend to prefer history
at what point do you bridge the gap
between understanding intermediate semis
full speech and full-on native speech
it's gradual and you'll suddenly notice
some days you understand clearly some
days you don't um
yeah it's just a gradual gradual process
the brain the brain learns the brain
starts sorting things out but the brain
learns slowly
have you ever considered to add dialects
together with languages at league well
we do have
different forms of arabic at least like
levantine arabic and egyptian arabic um
because the script is the same
uh
again the word dialect like who decides
that levantine arabic is a dialect and
not a language i don't know why is
portuguese a language and not a dialect
of spanish or vice versa for that matter
uh danish and norwegian and swedish or
the languages or dialects it's all very
you know
arbitrary
uh if we have a request to put up a
certain language whether it's considered
a dialect or not we will certainly look
at it if we get the many stories
is it no
have you ever considered okay is it true
that canadian accent is the easiest a
it's the easiest for me uh i don't know
i think the canadian accent is
relatively neutral
so i find for many people say the
scottish accent or the australian accent
or say uh
accent from the southern us would be
considered difficult and the canadian
accent which is similar to some irish
accents by the way
is fairly neutral
do i need to translate every foreign
word into my mother tongue no i
certainly don't ah cheers from ukraine
i'm going there
in may second half of may yuri
and i'm looking forward i i must have
had a great time i was in uh life which
is a lovely city
and traveled down to uh the carpathian
mountains and then to tennessee
and then i was in kiev but this time i'm
going to nipro
and i'm going
to visit some people in eastern ukraine
who are helping uh
you know
people who are suffering from the war
there
people that i've been helping a little
bit and then i'm coming back to kiev and
then in to la viv to work on my
ukrainian some more
how long has the live been on for
since we started the 98 challenge the
first of february
oh today all right 52 minutes yeah i'm
kind of running out of time here cheers
mate did steve already tackle the topic
i came oh which topic uh i may have
missed that
now
do you think pitch accent is important
when starting japanese
i am actually quite fluent in japanese i
was able to do business
i understand it i have never concerned
myself with pitch
i wouldn't be able to tell you what
pitch is
okay uh impact on link article 11 and 13
i don't know if it becomes a problem
we'll change how we
allow content to be uploaded to our
libraries
uh you know what it's a very interesting
question vocalmatic to do something like
volume discounts i want to look into uh
what we can do with vocalomatic or any
number of these other
uh transcription services i'm going to
talk about this with mark i'm going to
wait till i get back to vancouver which
will be in mid-april
still experimenting with the system i
think that's something that we need to
look at how we can use these automatic
transcription services to integrate them
with link good question ian
full-time friends hi steve i just
dropped by to say congratulations on
100k subscriptions thank you
i think you have to do a questionnaire
to learn that people want more advanced
story stories it would be great my
native language is greek oh yeah okay
i'd love to have some for greek um john
kr
um
yeah again it's it's a project let me
look at it uh when i get back to
vancouver uh about uh adding more
uh
more advanced uh uh stories and don't
forget too that one of the things about
the mini stories is that there's a very
heavy focus on
the highest frequency vocabulary
so you know at some point but i think it
is useful it's easier for me to learn
vocabulary in many stories than
if i go to a podcast
and uh you know the vocabulary doesn't
reappear that often um
yeah somehow you know if if yeah i think
it's i think it's something that i would
like to do but let me worry about it
when i get back
uh
all right
i think because we're now 10 59 it's
gone on for an hour is it okay to become
japanese but not know the etiquette and
do business in japan
there is no way you're going to be
fluent in japanese and not have a sense
of the etiquette
essentially
the the the amount of
japanese etiquette you need to know can
be explained to you in five minutes and
it's not that different from okay you
take your shoes off if you go into
someone's house when someone gives you a
name card you don't just throw it on the
table you don't throw your name card at
someone you give your name card at least
that's when i was there maybe they don't
use name cards now you receive a name
card you show an interest in it uh you
let people speak
uh you don't tell people how great you
are that's the biggest problem north
americans have is my product is the best
and this is the best and we're the best
that doesn't go over well in japan so i
mean i could explain all that in five
minutes
the bigger problem is people who think
that there's a major issue with
etiquette in japan there isn't unless
you unless you are rude by
nature
uh you won't be perceived as rude by the
japanese so
you know this whole etiquette thing is
blown out of proportion to be successful
in business in japan this is for anton
you have to do what you say you're going
to do
one of the things in japan is like there
are culture cultures where people over
promise yeah i can do that i'm the best
i can do this that doesn't work in japan
in japan you say gee i don't know i'll
try my best i'll i'll try my best to
you know
do what you're asking me to do
so that kind of understated approach and
then delivering on what you say you're
going to do and that's true everywhere
but it's particularly true in japan
should i care about grammar writing
systems learning japanese just go
straight on learning as many sentences
invoke if you learn lots of sentences
and vocabs your grammar will look after
yourself and in order to be able to read
what you need to do to learn vocab
you'll need to know the writing system
have you ever attended vancouver
entrepreneurs group and if so no i
haven't
to be a good speaker how many words
should i have depends on the language
but
normally 15 000.
uh
yeah alaikum salaam absolutely okay
we're now over the hour so thank you for
listening
and bye for now